last week we did the story on this study
about how in 2060 basically because of
an aging population that's going to stay
alive and people having less kids that
our whole economic system can be flipped
upside down we're gonna a class war
between old people and young people read
Albert Brooks 2030 if you haven't
now futurologists are saying they well
they're basically making bold
predictions about what's going to happen
in 2040 to the workforce this is from
expat jobs calm let's take a look so
here are some of the things that they
predict will be happening by 2040 this
is not that long for now we may be
requesting Bionic implants for our hands
that will make us able to perform tasks
as fast as any machine Plastic Surgeons
will be able to offer additional brain
processing power I could use that the
current 37.4 our work week will increase
a third to fifty and a half hours and we
will have less sex in a lifetime as a
result of reduced human interaction I
think some of these things are already
happening
so let's look at what the worker will
look like in 2040 workers will have red
eyes from working all hours also may be
from being the Terminator weaker eyes
from close-up wearable devices much like
Google glass that we've been talk a lot
about a smaller penis as a result of
fewer sexual partners over a lifetime as
human interaction reduces I didn't know
that your penis grows in relation to how
much sex you're having a bigger brain
with software and memory updates we're
just going to put a little will SIM card
in our ear I guess implanted ear wear to
eliminate cumbersome Bluetooth headsets
and smartphones and smart fingers with
chips that aid work ok so I painted the
future for you 2040 you're not buying it
this is such nonsense
we're gonna look back at this segment
exactly Pat stipes max jobs that come
I'm calling shenanigans yeah we're gonna
look back at this segment the same way
we look back at Popular Mechanics issues
from the 40s you know Oh cities will fly
high above us like no it's this won't
happen the idea that technology is going
to reduce sexual interaction is crazy if
anything we've seen the exact opposite
to be true Google glass is not gaining a
foothold if anything people are
rejecting
the weirdness of it uh I think being
conditioned by years and years and years
of dystopian future movies and novels
has made us very suspicious of the
computers that saw commenters tell me
every week I watch way too many sci-fi
yeah we're not that we're not going to
be like oh we can have a droid that can
do our jobs yeah I'd like to hire that
droid I know I shouldn't smoke we watch
Total Recall every night before I go to
know that you should do because that's
just a good life choice but uh this is
just it I mean it's fun to think about
but it's also crazy not so okay I'm
gonna fight back a little bit on that
but I'll let you go first
I grieve jack although I do want to be I
do want to be that person who's like
TV's a fabric I want to look back in the
other way Billy's these guys and believe
us we're totally right you want to be
back at I want to be the guy who's wrong
but um no I think it's all it's it's
complete but I do think the sex
parts actually true I disagree jack on
that I think that um we have reduced
interaction and that the movie her was
like very true to life or will be bred
some time will we will be able to kind
of find connectivity and sort of a
sexual release outside of human partners
right well already I mean I don't know
if you know this but there's porn on the
internet heard about that yeah I haven't
haven't seen any but I've heard that
that's a thing yeah I would argue that
the last 20 years have led to a much
more promiscuous like I feel like
society's much more promiscuous now than
it was in the 1950s right and a big part
of that is because we're watching a lot
of porn and where people are getting
married much later in life you know it's
it's the number of 20-somethings I know
myself included who are like oh I'm not
even gonna think about getting married
till I'm 30
you like that would never that would
have been crazy talk in 19 1950 and you
know the rise of tinder and Grindr and
it's these things are made so people can
like get their rocks off together like
no but right you know right there's
plenty of room to do it alone but yes
you can do it I don't think anybody's
been like you know porns been so great
I'm just done with sex like I don't I
think of anything it has the opposite
effect where I don't know yeah if you
could have a sex robot over having to
deal with the human being I feel like
you might go over the sex we've talked a
lot about the sex robots they're coming
too no pun intended
they're coming
I think I think so sir I think you nail
that right there about people uh Don
Draper's worried about how to pitch the
sex
exactly so okay so I to me it seems like
a lot of this stuff is actually possible
because it's only twenty something years
in the future and if you think about
what what we were like twenty years ago
we didn't know about phones our pocket
we were connected to the internal time
we wouldn't even be able to believe all
the stuff we could do now so that's why
I look at this list and yet maybe our
eyes won't be turning red but like the
rest of it seems kinda yeah like we
can't nobody can predict what when you
know there's that famous quote from the
Microsoft guy in like 1981 and he's like
no we're the future we'll ever anyone
ever need more than four megabytes of
data you know like I feel like that's
why I kinda buy into this am I crazy
futurist you're insane I think that no
III get that I think that but at the
same time like the things that have
happened
we've dictum accent like exactly no but
the things have happened I think are
also kind of in line with what we
expected to some degree like video calls
I mean what what is actually happening
that's that outside of what we could've
imagined
right what we thought the video calls to
be on this big machine and it ended up
in our in our hands right so I mean yeah
I these things happen but they happen in
such extreme ways only by 2040 were to
see it drastically different I mean
there might be a nuclear war that
weapons all out before that but if if we
survive story this week we're gonna if
we survive I don't need to be that
drastically different um any sees happen
kind of gradually as they're happening
is it feels that way so I don't think
it's gonna be somewhere to wake up
suddenly with robots working all our
jobs yeah I also think technology has
made us more connected then maybe I'm
buying what Mark Zuckerberg is selling
but I do think technology's made us more
connected than we've ever been I have
met I met both of you on the internet
the guy through Twitter and through I
had nothing to do a sec yeah no yeah
well first but no I mean I like this is
a human interaction that's occurring
that wouldn't have occurred when this is
being broadcast or the you know like
it's the we're becoming more I don't
think human interaction is is lessening
and I don't think that anybody is
thinking that oh if only I could just
talk to smarter child or one of those
other like
her bot or one of those instead of being
on Twitter like interacting with actual
people I think we may have less
face-to-face contact at some point but I
think there will always be a need for
face-to-face contact and I think even
video calls we're about face-to-face
contact like it's and even that's not
really take I mean Skype is a big part
of meetings and big but the idea of like
talking to your friend in the same city
on a video call I still feel like is
like not the most common thing despite
what you know some TV shows because it's
a clever it's an easy way to get people
in the same room like I don't think
that's like really taken off in a huge
way I think in 20 in 2040 things are
gonna look a lot like they will now only
with maybe like smaller phones and
hopefully their cars play giant retro
phone all the Zach Mars
yeah let's go yeah